in this video we're going to think about
analog versus digital signals
and one way to think about the
difference is an analog signal is trying
to reproduce exactly in some type of a
signal what is going on while a digital
signal is converting it usually to ones
and zeros which then can be converted
back so the first thing to realize is
that almost any type of information it
might be how intense a certain color is
or how bright it is or it might be a
frequency of sound all of that can be
represented as numbers so whether you're
trying to transmit an analog signal or a
digital signal it really is about how do
you communicate numbers using some type
of signal and as an example let's say
that you are trying to communicate the
number 24 to someone well one way to do
it is as an analog signal
you could have as time goes on maybe
this is some type of voltage across a
wire and if you put that voltage right
at what the other person receiving it
could it interpret it as 24
well then you would transmit it and they
might if they get this nice clean signal
see it as a 24.
now the problem with analog signals is
what happens when you have interference
so let's say this is a really long wire
that you're transmitting it over or
you're transmitting it using radio waves
and there's a lot of bad weather or
other types of interference and so on
the receiving end
even though you transmit something that
looks like this that is a clear 24
the other person might get something
like this
and so this isn't obvious that is a 24
anymore it goes between 20 and 30 and
this could be interpreted as static or
garbled up message or just doesn't sound
as clean depending what the 24 is trying
to represent or the image isn't as clear
if this is representing say the the
lightness or the brightness of a pixel
now the other option is to convert that
24 into
binary
so 24 can be represented in binary as
one one
zero zero zero
now we have other videos on khan academy
that explain how to convert back and
forth between our decimal system that
has ten digits zero through nine and the
binary system which has two digits zero
and one but in case you're curious and
you don't have to understand this to
know the difference between analog and
digital signals and when they might be
useful this first place is the ones
place just as you're used to but instead
of this being the tens place this is the
two's place instead of this being the
hundreds place this is the fourth place
instead of this being the thousands
place this is the eighths place and
instead of that being the ten thousands
place that's the sixteens place
so one way to think about it one one
zero zero zero means one sixteen and one
eight and if you add those together you
would get twenty four
what would that actually look like as a
signal
well it could look something like this
where the person interpreting it knows
that over this first time period
whatever voltage you're getting that
tells you your first digit
then over the next time period whatever
voltage you're getting tells you the
second digit and so on and so forth so
this would be one one
zero zero zero
now why is this useful well let's think
about the situation where all of a
sudden there's interference again
now with the interference you could
still interpret this exactly as one one
zero zero zero remember the person
receiving the signal or the system
receiving the signal is just trying to
determine whether it's getting a one or
a zero so even though this is being
perturbed right over here it's clear
that we are at a one we know that it
would not be a point nine or one point
one it has to be either one or a zero so
it's clear that over
this part right over here you're getting
a one and then over here you're getting
three zeros so they would be able to
interpret it as one one zero zero zero
which is once again exactly twenty four